well new tonight the family of a man
killed in a hit-and-run crash
are pleading for someone to come forward
the crash happened last week right near
lake mead and lamp
sasha loftis on this story joining us
live from the east valley tonight
with a story you will only see right
here on 8 news now
brian this is where renek lambie lost
his what life just
over a week ago his family is
understandably
devastated and they are now determined
to find out
who did this to him the 61 year old was
riding his motorized wheelchair
here along this road last thursday
evening when police say he was hit and
killed by a car
the driver took off without stopping to
help him renek's wife and son
spoke with me tonight about the person
he was and how they will always miss him
they're now begging anyone with any
information to come forward
i love him from the day that i met him
until the day he left this earth my love
remains the same
and it all stays the same forever and
ever
and i want to say to the community
anyone in the community
community that hears anything or see
anything
i am asking from my heart
please come forward please say something
diana and her son described renick as
incredibly kind with an infectious sense
of humor
he simply loved life and fought off
countless illnesses
only to die like this he was
a caring man a giving man a man with
dreams that he
lived every day he never ever
had a bad thought about anyone he was a
loving man he never saw a race
he just saw life
again police are still investigating and
searching for the person who hit renek
here on abel's lane
last thursday that's again right near
lake mead and lamb now the family is
also raising money through a gofundme to
hire their own
separate private investigator to again
find the suspect in this case
if you'd like to help we have a link to
that on our website 8newsnow.com
reporting live in the northeast valley
sasha loftis 8 news now